molly needed you you're my favorite
deputy this is just one of the many
iconic lines brought to life by the
actors behind our favorite toys let's
take a look at the voices that created
these characters any other toy would
give up his moving parts just to be you
chris evans was tapped to fill the role
of buzz lightyear for the 2022 film
light year following up tim allen's
iconic role is a big task but evan seems
up to the challenge he expressed his
appreciation on twitter i can't believe
that i get to be a part of the pixar
family and work with these truly
brilliant artists director agnes mclean
said chris evans was his first and only
choice and that evans understood the
material and the character to infinity
and
there is no toy story character more
iconic than woody it was tom hanks first
voice acting gig who thrived in the role
we all knew operation play time was a
long shot he actually recorded two
versions of the first movie as the
creators didn't like the first script so
they rewrote it and re-recorded it again
hanks explained that the recording
sessions could be stressful on his voice
and body i have driven home after a four
or five hour sometimes 6 hour recording
session and my diaphragm just it hurts
it aches in order to record the more
emotional scenes hanks had to either
close his eyes or turn his back to the
people in the room
tim allen's buzz lightyear voice is
easily recognizable but it's apparently
also scary as he once scared a child in
an elevator by using the voice buzz
lightyear mission log the local sheriff
and i seem to be at a huge refueling
station of some sort
scaring kids aside allen has given his
all into the character speaking on toy
story 4 allen said he got emotional
watching the film it brought up some of
my own personal stuff about loss change
moving on it's heartwarming don't worry
in just a few hours you'll be sitting
around a campfire with andy making
delicious hot schmoes the cowgirl jessie
introduced in toy story 2 was joan
cuzak's first voice acting role fellas
i know what to do she stated how
different it was only using her voice to
act as opposed to live action as there
were no costumes or makeup to worry
about it was kind of cool to refocus on
just your voice and you know making
something crisper clear cuzak said that
playing jessie was about believing in
yourself and what you can do and we
would say she nailed it sweet mother of
abraham lincoln toy story 4 director
josh cooley found keanu reeves when he
was listening to soundbites of potential
actors he thought his voice was perfect
for the role of duke kaboom but didn't
think he was going to be able to get
reeves to voice the part however keanu
was excited about the role and actually
stood up on a table to act out the part
during a meeting with the director duke
kaboom canada's greatest stuntman reeves
didn't find the experience too different
from live action as he said it's the
same concept of finding the right voice
and tone of a character hold on one more
oh yeah wallace sean had a great time
voicing rex for all four toy story
movies what if andy gets another
dinosaur a mean one he never lost touch
with the character even after playing
him for 24 years no matter how much time
has passed when it comes time to do it
again that dinosaur still seems to be in
me i don't have to warm up he magically
leaps into me he loves knowing that his
character can give people joy and stated
that sometimes kids recognize his voice
in public
the late comedian don rickles portrayed
mr potato head in the first three toy
story films hey look i'm picasso he was
a little hesitant to take the part at
first as he had never done voice over
work for an animated character before
luckily he changed his mind and gave mr
potato head the unique voice we know
rickles passed away before toy story 4
but they used old recordings of his to
bring the character to life one more
time his daughter stated he would be
proud as he always said keep my name
alive let them know who i am you're not
a toy you're an accessory you're a press
with legs
right alongside mr potato head is his
wife mrs potato head voiced by the
lovely estelle harris oh you found it
this was not her first voice acting role
but it was one of her favorites as she
had a great time voicing the character
someplace dark
and dusty she described how it's a bit
difficult to know what you're recording
as they only gave her a couple pages at
a time without much context she was
skeptical about one recording in
particular where she had to make ninja
like noises but loved it after seeing it
in the movie
[Music]
toy story 2 introduced the character of
al an avid toy collector portrayed by
wayne knight i got a pack let's see
wallet keys tickets it wasn't knight's
first time doing voice work for disney
as he had previously voiced demetrius in
hercules and tantor in tarzan knight
compared voice work to other types of
acting doing animation is interesting in
the sense that you put all your emotions
through your voice it's over the top in
a way that you don't do on stage or film
hopefully knight never had to drive all
the way to work on a saturday to voice
the toy collector
toy story 2 director john lasseter was a
big fan of kelsey grammer's portrayal of
the prospector kelsey's comic timing is
beautiful his acting it's just fantastic
grammar joked that he didn't know his
character's nickname was stinky p and
that it destroyed his career turn me
around bullseye
so i can see
ducky was a new character introduced in
toy story 4. keegan michael key voiced
the plush and had a great time voicing
the role alongside his longtime friend
jordan peele the comedic duo didn't miss
a beat and would improvise songs during
their recordings which made it into the
movie
[Music]
director josh cooley said working with
key was one of the highlights of his
pixar career cheat the system and get
with the kid yeah we know john
ratzenberger is well known at pixar and
his voice is even more well known by the
public as he has provided his voice for
every single pixar movie his first role
however was as ham in toy story even
with his incredible resume ratzenberger
took very little credit for the pixar
characters he has voiced over the years
as he said pixar is doing all the heavy
lifting all you really do is listen to
what they tell you very simple get ready
for porkchop lotso was the purple bear
villain in toy story 3 portrayed
masterfully by ned beatty first thing
you got to know about me is i'm a hugger
director lee unkrich wanted someone who
could be both comedic and dramatic which
beatty has done both in previous roles
so he was the perfect choice when coming
up with the tone and demeanor for lotso
baby stated unkrich knew exactly what he
wanted and it was just a matter of
finding the right dialect for the bear
welcome to sunnyside folks the late jim
varney voiced slinky dog in both toy
story 1 and 2 which was his first voice
over role as an animated character in
his lifetime he only voiced three
animated characters including this one
he provided his unique raspy voice to
bring slinky to life i knew you'd come
back woody forkey is one of the latest
additions to the toy story crew he's
voiced by tony hale an experienced voice
actor with plenty of animated character
roles under his belt with that said hill
stated he was nervous to be joining such
a beloved franchise so late in the game
but the cast and fans welcomed him with
open arms he played forkey as if he was
a child new to the world without an
understanding of how anything works and
we would say his portrayal was spot on i
am not a toy i'm a spork we love the toy
story films and the voices behind our
favorite characters bringing these
iconic characters to life was no easy
task but these voice actors absolutely
nailed their roles which toy story
character is your favorite